from Colin Trevorrow treviri Rio cerebro
from not Steven Spielberg comes the best
Jurassic Park sequel ever made which
really isn't saying much Allan Jurassic
world it's been 22 years since Jurassic
Park opened its gates but today's kids
don't care about an old fashioned
dinosaur zoo now desperate for more
profits Jurassic world is here with
cooler new dinosaurs better amenities
and tons of product placement Verizon
Wireless presents the indominus rex to
exploit a new generation by selling them
the same basic premise they already sold
to their parents to the point where they
literally break out a pair of nostalgia
goggles wait are we talking about the
movie or the reason this movie exists I
really can't tell anymore
that first part was legit welcome to
Jurassic world an awesome dinosaur
version of SeaWorld
that's another blackfish documentary
waiting to happen where once again
they've spared no expense and expands
yet after a string of highly public
disasters where dinosaurs escaped they
still have crappy fences invisible
fences were no fell that is the second
time this month bad security security we
need a search and rescue in the valley
gonna be a while and conveniently bad
reception indicates a new week
okay Zach listen tack hello
should have taken that Verizon deal you
remember the original films great
characters like Alan Grant and Ian
Malcolm now meet uh this stiff lady who
won't shut up about assets doesn't mean
asset development to spawn behind we've
unveiled a new asset asset containment
and out of containment can we just focus
on the asset please and this Chris Pratt
who won't shut up about animals don't
learn anything about these animals
except what you want to know I'll be
easier to pretend these animals are just
wild animals how long has the animal
been in here animals raised in
isolationist animal animal animal
animals animals together with a bunch of
other one-dimensional characters whose
names I cannot seem to remember they'll
have to thwart engines plan to strap
cameras on barely trained Raptors heads
and use them to hunt terrorists in
Afghanistan these guys are gonna run
straight into the enemy's teeth and eat
them but buck on all wait what I need to
read that again engines playing the
strap no that's what it says message we
have these puppies in Tora Bora
wow that is like a dr. evil level of
stupid right there I have one simple
request and that is to have sharks with
frickin laser beams attached to their
heads after just ten years of operation
the public is somehow already bored of
living breathing dinosaurs
now instead of creating new herbivore
hybrids the same guy responsible for the
first dinosaur disaster will combine the
two deadliest carnivores on the island
t-rex and Raptor thanks barb
and snake I say I can sense thermal
radiation like snakes and tree frog tree
frogs can use strands from their DNA
tanned cuttlefish cuttlefish chains were
added dude stop you had me a t-rex
Raptor
this isn't Pinkberry you're not to use
every topping just cuz they're they're
so experienced the box-office smash of
the summer that's really just the most
expensive sci-fi channel original movie
ever made
that gave bored zookeepers something to
do this summer and had everyone asking
how that lady outran a t-rex in high
heels but somehow give a pass to all
these other questions like is the CEO
really the only helicopter pilot on a
chain of small islands you don't need
anyone else why would they give a
dinosaur created for public display the
ability to camouflage is the assistants
death see cool or extremely excessive
and unjustified why do you have one fat
lazy security guard for the most
dangerous animal on the planet it
doesn't make any sense
why can't BD Wong tell the park
management what he put in their dinosaur
didn't they pay for it that's
unfortunate can the Moses horse eat
anything that wanders next to his tank
why are these kids parents getting
divorced and why is that even in the
movie why aren't any of these girls
calling the police on this Creek what do
you think's gonna happen from you're
just staring at them why do these two
characters hook up in spite never really
liking each other who's in charge of
this control room a dinosaur is
literally eating people and they're all
just sitting there is there no head of
security that's a first
what is this lady's job exactly she does
not even know what she is is this the
worst written villain ever Jesus wait
did that rapper just jump on that she
races back to get leverage because
that's awesome and how can the tour
ballers leave the park when today's
technology won't even let you take a
shopping cart 20 feet from the grocery
store I Wikus that oh come one minutes
but who cares
cuz that t-rex and Raptor tag-team fight
was awesome
starring zoo Lord Bryce Dallas Texas
Vincent donut freedos human BuzzFeed
Bill Nye the evil guy Shan
mooo Tyrannosaurus ex machina near my
boy blue and the plot asaurus rex raptor
rex vs dino shark you know for such a
ridiculous movie they really nail was
like to watch a Jimmy Fallon sketch am i
right is this real it is be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers
cookie cat he's a friend for your tummy
what killed the dinosaurs the Ice Age
welcome to Jurassic Park hit the Quan I
am Reptar hear me roar I'm not saying
that you can't make me say that stop
asking me